Like we were just talking about, when you look at the expression, X squared
minus 1, it's sometimes hard to remember that it's factorable because it looks
so simple. It's kind of not that intuitive, that expression that has 2 terms.
Can be factored to equal the product of 2 expressions that each have 2 terms. I
know that I was pretty blown away when I first learned about the differences of
2 squares. And how it's factorable. What if instead of the difference of two
squares though, we had the difference of two cubes. Something like Y cubed minus
Z cubed. Since the difference of two squares is factorable, maybe this is too.
I've given you 3 choices here, 2 of which are possible factorizations of Y cubed
minus Z cubed, and the third choice, which is that this expression is not
factorable. Please pick what you think is the best choice.